they're chanting not one more women
who've taken over this toll booth on the
outskirts of Mexico City to protest
against years of femicides there's so
much violence I don't know any woman who
hasn't suffered and here on the
outskirts where the Forgotten ones
here's where they come to throw the
bodies more than ten women are killed
every day across the country and it's
getting worse in 2019 the number was
doubled out of four years previously but
this month the issue came to a head with
two horrific murders
Ingrid Escamilla was stabbed and flayed
seven-year-old Fatima al delegate was
kidnapped outside her school then raped
and strangled
after Ingrid's murder this is what
President Lopez Obrador had to say I
don't want the theme of this press
conference to just be about femicides
it's very clear that issue has been
really manipulated by the media those
who don't like us take advantage of any
circumstance to generate campaigns of
deformation we like to blame the issue
on social decay caused by neoliberalism
it outraged many I can't even describe
it we're talking about a national
emergency of femicides and we have two
cases that really blew everything up and
then the president says no don't get
distracted this isn't important so what
is important what are his priorities is
President women's rights advocates say
on paper protocols exist to deal with
violence against women but in practice
they're often ignored by authorities who
can themselves be abusive I've been
sexually assaulted by police and you
have to face up to it alone that's
because the people that show support and
solidarity with you are in Mexico City
not here but in the last year women have
been coming together more and more to
demand change there's a relatively small
number of women here but protests like
this one have been increasing across the
country after years in which authorities
have really done not very much to
prevent femicides and abuses against
women now the pressures on
down the 9th of March a national strike
for women has been called the movement
is only growing John Holman al Jazeera
he had to Peck